MEGAN SMITH: Hello, and
welcome to Women Techmakers.
This is a series where we bring
incredible technical women
to screen.
And I'm joined by this amazing
robotics brain trust today.
Cori Lanthan is the CEO and
founder of AnthroTronix,
and she's going to tell us
about that and her other work.
And Yoky Matsuoka is here,
who is the VP of technology
at Nest, and she has an
incredible also robotics
background.
So welcome to both of you.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Thanks.
CORI LATHAN: Thank you.
MEGAN SMITH: So I think that the
robotics future is so exciting,
and you guys came in really
early into this world.
You, through an
incredible athletic twist,
which I want you to talk
about, that Yoky came in.
And Cori, you through
the space entry.
So maybe talk a
little bit about that,
and we'll come to what
you're doing in a minute.
So how did you get
into this world?
YOKY MATSUOKA:
Yeah, so it's really
different from many people--
how people get into robotics.
But when I was growing up, there
were no initiatives with robots
yet.
And I was a tennis
player-- tennis junkie--
that's all I knew how to do.
And in college, when I was
getting a lot of injuries,
I was searching
for something else.
And I picked the most
athletically interesting
engineering, which
happened to be robotics.
So I stumbled upon a lab that
was building a hopping robot.
And I thought, this is
kind of like tennis.
If I'm going to build a little
tennis buddy robot for myself,
then I've got to learn how
to do this hopping and legged
robotic work.
So that's where I started.
MEGAN SMITH: One of the things
that happens a lot in school
is that some of the ways
we teach science and math
kind of turn kids off to it,
because they're not actually
doing it.
They're learning
the history of it.
So they don't really
experience how to make stuff.
YOKY MATSUOKA: That's so true.
Yeah, actually--
MEGAN SMITH: Was there
something early in your history
that taught you,
hey, I can do this?
YOKY MATSUOKA: You know
what, I didn't even
connect that math
and all those things
are connected to
what I wanted to do.
I liked math, and I was
good at it, but that was it.
MEGAN SMITH: So you
can much later to this.
YOKY MATSUOKA: My brain
was totally somewhere else.
MEGAN SMITH: And
you were nationally
ranked tennis player.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Yeah.
Nationally ranked.
Yeah.
That's right.
And then the
connection happened--
like robotics, that's fun.
I want to build things.
That would be really fun to do.
And then turns out, it's
like, oh, math is useful.
And computer science is useful.
All those things slowly
start to come into places.
MEGAN SMITH: Cori, we
have a funny overlap
because my freshman job was
with Professor Dave Akin at MIT,
and that building
machining stuff
as a junior person on
the space systems lab.
And he later went to Maryland,
where you were on the faculty
adjunct, and you worked
with them, I think.
So I know that you did a lot
of really interesting work
with robotics and people in
space, putting things together.
Talk a little bit about that.
And also, early on,
how you'd come in?
CORI LATHAN: Well,
my interest really
came from being a space junkie.
So you were a tennis junkie,
I was a space junkie.
And I was fascinated
with science fiction.
I read science
fiction voraciously
and loved Star Trek.
And so I think that
combined with-- I
really wanted to know, how do
humans live and work in space.
I wanted to be an astronaut.
And so that is what inspired
me to learn more about what
does it take to have humans
live and work in space.
And that's what propelled me, I
think, into a graduate program
of aerospace
engineering, and then
finding out the
technologies that
were emerging that
could enable this.
Certainly we know about
robots from science fiction.
Well, what robots were
actually available?
Or what technologies
were actually available?
And so it was, at the
time, a very exciting time
to make it real.
Yeah.
MEGAN SMITH: Very cool.
It's interesting
about Star Trek,
because I was watching the
Maker Series, makers.com,
which is all these incredible
stories about women.
And they had Nichelle Nichols,
who played Lieutenant Uhura,
and there was a
moment that she talked
about where Martin Luther
King came and was talking
to her about why it was
so important that she was
in the team-- they need women
and minorities in that team.
He actually said that it was
so important for civil rights
for her to be in
everyone's living room.
And I think the role modeling
of media and stories come out,
it's interesting.
CORI LATHAN: Yeah, and
that actually brings
to mind-- there was a great
Star Trek episode between Spock
and Uhura where
she's freaking out
because they're in some
crisis and she said,
I don't know if I can do this.
And Spock says, I can think of
no better person for the job.
MEGAN SMITH: Nice.
CORI LATHAN: And I'm like, yes!
MEGAN SMITH: It's incredible.
And that's actually a theme.
You notice that
sometimes women sometimes
don't have as much confidence.
And so to have a colleague, in
this case a fictional character
colleague, just
reinforce how qualified
you are is a really great thing.
So, nice media moment.
So now you guys have moved
out of those original places
and into your current
roles, which are just
incredibly breakthrough places.
So can you guys
talk a little bit
about Nest-- what you guys
are trying to achieve,
what your vision is there?
Talk a little bit
about AnthroTronix
and what the vision is there.
So maybe go with Yoky.
YOKY MATSUOKA:
Sure, I can start.
I think my passion
with Nest is really
about human interaction
with devices.
And what we build at Nest
is no longer something
that people might
imagine as robots.
It's mounted on the wall.
It doesn't have legs.
It doesn't move.
But it's essentially
the same thing.
It actually controls
house temperature.
It monitors through sensors
about all the things
that's happening in the house.
So we still consider
it to be a robot.
And so now, what can we do?
Really the true goal
is about letting people
be who they want to
be, because now they're
living with some intelligent
technology on the wall.
MEGAN SMITH: So not try to have
them adapt to the technology,
but have the technology
be more fluid.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Yeah, to let
them be who they want to be.
So here's an example.
So Nest thermostat--
turns out 50%
of the energy used in
a residential space
is by heating and
cooling the house.
We didn't know that.
And so if we could actually
even save 10% or 20% of that,
that's a huge chunk of it.
So how can we do it?
And if we ask people, do
you like to save energy?
Everybody says, of course I do.
And then if you say, well,
did you turn off the lights
when you left home?
They say, yes.
And then when you say, well,
did you turn off the heating
when you left home?
They're like, um,
I can't remember.
Lighting is 10%.
Heating is 50%.
Why do we know to turn off
the light, but not heating?
So why don't we augment
with the technology?
When we know that
they've left the house,
why don't we turn
it down for them?
So those are the places where
we're a little bit weak at,
but technology's good at.
Why don't we understand
where that right intersection
is and do the right
thing for them,
without removing
control from people?
MEGAN SMITH: Right.
Because you let people
control from their app.
They can control from
the device itself.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Yeah.
And then there is a schedule
that we learn over time,
because people are relatively
predictable when they leave.
So the machines, they learn
for them, but at the same time,
people can always override them.
And it's incredibly important.
Through even experiments,
it's really interesting.
Through the field trial, we
learned that the moment we
interfere a little bit with
people's decision making,
they get all mad.
So that's one of
the things that we
learn as well through robotics.
We really respect
what they want,
and then still try to achieve
the same goal with them.
MEGAN SMITH: It's interesting,
because from science fiction,
maybe we think robots
are like Terminator--
these extreme things.
And perhaps some of them
will be humanoid in that way,
but I think the point that
robotic or assistive technology
can be exactly in the
direction that NASA's going,
or what Roomba was doing
with cleaning robots.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Task specific.
MEGAN SMITH: I work with some
of my colleagues at Google X,
and they have the
self-driving car.
So that's really
kind of a robot,
in a way-- taking
a transport robot.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Completely.
Yeah,
MEGAN SMITH: So thinking
about robotics in that way.
So say--
CORI LATHAN: Well
I'd love to build
on what Yoky was saying,
because it really resonates
with the work that we're doing.
I mean, we've been hearing
about the internet of things.
And what that means
to me practically
is the traditional
idea of a robot, which
is this humanoid-type thing
or this standalone piece
of machinery, has really changed
over the past 10 or 15 years
as the consumer electronics
revolution has exploded.
So a robot is simply a
sensor, some processing,
and an actuator.
So our smartphones
are now robots.
YOKY MATSUOKA: That's right.
CORI LATHAN: So the work
you're doing, as you said,
it's still robotics.
And so bringing it back
to some of the things
that I've been doing in
my company, AnthroTronix,
so Anthro, human,
Tronix, instrumentation.
And we've looked at for
the past 10 or 15 years,
how do you capture human
capability and use that
to interface to an
electronic platform?
And in the early days,
that electronic platform
was a robot.
So for example, we
worked with kids
with disabilities trying
to capture their movements.
So a child with Cerebral Palsy
who had very spastic movements,
we could capture
those, and they could
operate a robot
who could explore
their environment, which was
something they couldn't do.
So now, we fast forward,
and we're doing things
like taking a
smartphone and capturing
both passive and
active movements
to learn about the status
of your brain function,
of your capabilities,
and use that information
to then operate on the world.
And in case with kids,
it might be a robot,
but it could be a computer.
In case of the elderly, it might
be something in your kitchen.
So the concept of taking
active and passive monitoring
and capturing that and using
that to interface to technology
is still very relevant today,
as it was 15 years ago.
MEGAN SMITH: Very much so.
Also I was thinking about
education a little bit-- just
the ability to be
watching or sensing
what the kids are feeling,
or how much they're actually
learning, and leveraging
them [INAUDIBLE].
CORI LATHAN: Yeah.
And I think there's
actually a lot of interest
right now in brain-computer
interfaces and the concept
of an intelligent
tutor as something
that actually can sense
how well are you learning.
And the technologies that
are being used to sense that
are really changing.
I mean, we now have EEG that's
accessible to consumers that
can say, yeah, you
really are getting it.
And so one of the things
that we've been working on
with the Navy is
actually team training.
How can you measure both
physiological and brain
response and other
aspects of the training
and the learning to say, is
the team really a good team?
Is the team learning
well together,
not just the individual?
MEGAN SMITH: That's interesting,
because Regina Dugan, who
led DARPA, who's now at
Google-- was at Motorola--
she was talking about some
work in the sports area
around-- they were calling it
hustle on a basketball court.
So not just looking
as a team at when
you have an astonishing player
like Michael Jordan or any
of these folks performing, but
when, Michael's doing really
well, who else is on the court.
And so who has amazing
hustle to play really
well in that context, and
the instrumentation of sports
in general, but the
instrumentation on behalf
of understanding teamwork
and collaboration,
both in that arena, but in any
arena is pretty interesting.
YOKY MATSUOKA: It's interesting.
Actually, before Nest,
the life that I had
was a professor also working in
this neuroscience and robotics
area.
And one of the things
that we realized
is that we can measure effort
through just robot contacting
with humans, and then simply
observing movements and how
active the movements
are, and what's
normal, what's not normal.
Those are the things
that really came through.
So in context of
stroke rehabilitation,
we realized that
we can even tell
when people were paying
attention or making
really good progress
compared to the last week.
And I think those things are
incredibly useful to mix in,
and as you say, with
the teams sports
too, who is currently putting
in, almost like hustling a lot,
and then who are the great
players to be combined with.
And then there's a
whole lot of things
that we might not be
able to bring out simply
by just-- humans are good
at getting those things out,
but I think just getting those
things out in a robotic form,
and especially in dealing
with people with disabilities,
I think that's
really fascinating.
MEGAN SMITH: It's
interesting because we all
have some part of MIT in
common, and there's a new plan
to start a center for
advanced human mechatronics,
and how do you help people.
Specifically, Hugh
Herr is leading that.
And he's someone who lost
his lower legs in a climbing
accident and made his own
amazing robotics legs.
And I encourage people to
watch the Ted Talk that he did.
On the Ted stage, he
was saying, can we
eliminate disability in general
by adopting these technologies?
And I think it's interesting,
the leveraging, what
you were talking about, the
effort, encouraging people,
knowing what's
going on with them
and helping to encourage them
so they can bring themselves
further ahead.
That's pretty interesting
medical opportunity
and learning opportunity.
YOKY MATSUOKA: We also have
a neuroscience background,
but there are
things that we don't
take advantage of that we know.
For example, when
people have stroke,
there's a lot of time that
passes sitting in a hospital,
then going home,
and then their brain
is almost getting
worse and worse.
And we already know
in neuroscience
of like how long should we
wait, how long should we--
at some point, we
should aggressively
start rehabilitating.
So what if technology was
available to immerse them
in a right way at the right
time, already in the hospital?
So this big picture of a
virtual reality environment
where we put them, and
then they don't actually
even get to experience
this getting worse,
my movements are not
as good, but continue
to stimulate the
brain, so that when
they are ready to walk
out of the hospital,
they're much better off.
You know what's
interesting, I know
Mark Kelly, who's an
amazing astronaut,
and Gabby Giffords, his
wife, amazing Congresswoman
who was, unfortunately, shot.
Mark shared that when she went
to the hospital in Houston,
that one of the things they did
was exactly as you were saying.
Very early on, she was not
really quite conscious,
but they would lift
her up and begin
to do things-- help her body
physically-- her brain began
to work again with her
body in an interesting way.
So the speed to
helping someone recover
turns out to be, as you
said, really important.
So leveraging robotics
for that is interesting.
CORI LATHAN: And let me just
build on that for a moment.
I think the idea of
eliminating disability
is an amazing moon shot
idea that actually we
could go after.
And it's not just
eliminating disability.
How about eliminating aging?
And I don't mean
in this longevity,
you live forever thing.
I mean you eliminate
the disability
that seems to define aging.
As you get older, you have
the reduction of skills
and the reduction of activities.
If we could eliminate
that, I would
argue you've eliminated
aging as well.
And I think some of these
technologies that we're
talking about are
the key to that.
MEGAN SMITH: So
one of the themes
here is very much technology
in service of a purpose,
of impact.
And I know both of you guys
are involved a lot in helping
younger people see and
come into this field.
You have an organization
that you either founded
or are a part of.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
But I think somehow with
young people especially--
sometimes, as we said,
today in K to 12,
we're teaching science and
math in this boring way,
rather than, here's the stuff
that could really matter
for people's lives.
And by the way, you happen
to use science and math
as the language for it, and
bring it with the purpose.
So maybe say a little bit
about the organization
and what you're thinking.
CORI LATHAN: Sure.
I founded one organization, now
I'm actually part of another.
The organization that
I founded while I
was a grad student
at MIT is called Keys
to Empowering Youth.
And it was really my
"aha" moment, that really,
until I got to
graduate school, I
didn't know that women didn't go
in to science and engineering.
MEGAN SMITH: That's interesting.
Why was that?
CORI LATHAN: I think maybe
it's this personality of women
who-- I don't know.
YOKY MATSUOKA: I
totally agree, though.
Ignorance helps a little bit.
MEGAN SMITH: You know, the
women in physics say this, too.
Because the two areas
that continued to be lower
are computer science, 15% to
20%, and physics, 15% to 20%.
But people just power through.
CORI LATHAN: Yeah.
Until I got to grad
school, I really just
didn't even know that
this was an issue.
And so it really hit me
like a ton of bricks.
I mean, you're at MIT, which
the undergraduate population,
they're doing a much
better job at getting--
MEGAN SMITH: Yeah,
they're at almost 50/50,
or they're basically even.
CORI LATHAN: I don't know
if the graduate population
and the faculty has
budged from 20%--
MEGAN SMITH: It's coming up.
So you tend to see grad
school 30%, and then
the faculty anywhere from
10% in certain fields
to actually like 30% or 40%.
It just depends.
Chemical engineering is
very balanced, for example.
Or in some of the sciences,
like biology, are very balanced.
But a couple of the engineering
still, we've got to push them.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Megan know
this thing about MIT actually.
MEGAN SMITH: I do.
I'm on their board.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Because we're working on it.
It's important.
CORI LATHAN: I got
there in '89, and I
was one of two women
in my entering class
for graduate school, and often
the only woman in a class.
So it really hit me
like a ton of bricks.
And so I started doing all
reading and the research
and finding out all the
things that everyone already
knew-- that there
was this issue.
And I really was profoundly
affected by the Sadkers--
I think Myra and David Sadker--
I probably shouldn't even
say that because I don't
know the actual names.
I read some sociologists' work
about the lack of the brain
trust.
So I think this was my
awakening as a woman in science
and engineering.
And so I was looking at
that core-- at the time,
people were talking about
junior high and third, fourth,
fifth grade--
MEGAN SMITH: Where the
drop-offs were going.
CORI LATHAN: Where the
Well actually, I guess sixth,
seventh, eighth grade--
junior high.
And that spoke to
me as well because I
found that junior high had
been such a disempowering
experience for everybody.
MEGAN SMITH: Can we just
change how we do all that?
CORI LATHAN: So
for one IAP you can
propose, for the January term--
MEGAN SMITH: Because
the January break--
CORI LATHAN: January
break at MIT, we proposed,
let's bring these girls, 11 to
13, and bring them on campus
and just show them
all the cool stuff.
And so it went from there.
We started Keys to
Empowering Youth, science
and technology mentoring.
The idea is we
brought them on campus
to talk about stereotypes, show
them some great applications
of science and technology,
and do some problem solving.
And so that now,
it's still at MIT.
It's also at
University of Maryland.
I'm not involved with it at the
organizational level anymore,
but sometimes I'll go and speak.
So anyway-- sorry that
was a long answer.
MEGAN SMITH: But the key
point is the hands-on.
CORI LATHAN: I should
probably figure out
how to summarize that.
MEGAN SMITH: The
hands-on experience.
CORI LATHAN: Yeah.
It was to have the hands-on.
Really, the hands-on.
YOKY MATSUOKA: I think so, too.
I had started an organization
as well, in a nonprofit,
in almost exactly that format--
that there's an engineering
problem.
We specifically pick people
who could benefit from devices
that can enable
them in some way.
But then we specifically
formed a team
made of mostly young girls
to come up with a solution
that they can build on.
And that specifically targeted
about fifth through eight
grader girls.
And they just really connected
some of the school problems
that they didn't even think
was related and said, well,
why don't we use physics?
We can use this--
catapult this thing
over to this side of the body.
And I think that was
just a great connection
to really motivate
them to realize, wait,
the word "math"
and "engineering"
and all those things also
can relate to the world
like helping people.
And then somehow that was just
such an "aha" moment for them.
MEGAN SMITH: This is
the central issue.
We did some research, and
talking to girls and also boys
who are opting out of the
STEM fields, the STEAM fields,
and it was over and
over again, not really
connecting the impact-- not
really connecting the purpose.
And so if we can get
past that-- and you guys
are such an incredible
example of the kind of impact
and change you can
see in the world
by working on
these technologies.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Yeah.
Learning those examples
early on, right?
CORI LATHAN: Yeah.
And actually just wanted
to add one more thing.
One of the other
times that I think
it becomes very discouraging
for women in engineering
is in college and towards
the end of college.
You find that, I
think a lot of college
grads then move on
to something else.
They have this great
technical background,
but they go into
law or medicine.
They don't see that the
engineering can actually
help the world and
solve real problems.
MEGAN SMITH: Do
you think they are
doing that because they
don't feel welcome,
or they don't see the
purpose, you think?
Or some combination?
CORI LATHAN: I think it's
probably a combination of both.
And one of the other
organizations--
I'm on the board of Engineering
World Health, which takes
undergrad biomedical
engineers and gives
them experience abroad in
developing countries for 10
weeks.
And so it gives them this really
empowering, hands-on experience
over the summer during
their college time.
And I think it helps
them to really see
the application of
what they're doing.
And I think their
perception, right--
If you go to school of
nursing and then ask women,
why are you doing this?
And they said, because
we want to help people.
So, you know you could
also help in engineering.
She says, oh, I don't qualify.
I'm not good at it.
But then, what
makes you say that?
And then when you
drill down, they just
misunderstood what it
means to be good enough
to do the engineering.
MEGAN SMITH: And
also, unfortunately,
sometimes the amazing historic
women and minority leaders
aren't as well known.
We know Turing
really well, but we
don't know Grace Hopper as well.
We're starting to because of
the Grace Hopper Conference.
We know Babbage-- first
mechanical computer.
We don't know Ada, the first
person to suggest programming.
And so we need to work
on historic [INAUDIBLE].
YOKY MATSUOKA: And also
I think, role model.
I think women, because of a
little bit of the security--
because there are a
lack of role models,
they feel insecure
about themselves.
And then seeing more role models
seems to really help latch
on to girls and then
say, oh, I can do it too.
MEGAN SMITH: Yes.
even if it wasn't half-half.
If people were there.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
MEGAN SMITH: So speaking
of role models and heroes,
are there people that come
to mind for you guys-- have
have people that really
inspired you or helped you
when it was challenging?
Anybody come to mind
that's out there?
CORI LATHAN: It's funny,
because I remember
reading an interview
that you did,
and you were saying you
always had a hard time
thinking of role
models or something.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Role
model in a women forum
has been very difficult.
CORI LATHAN: That's
right, because I
was thinking the same thing.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Yeah.
CORI LATHAN: But to
answer your question,
when I was thinking
about that, two people
came to mind-- Captain Kirk.
So I find it very
interesting the male role
model's fictional, because then
the female would be Sally Ride.
So again, going back to
my space buff routes.
I think those were two very
inspirational models for me.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Interesting.
So for me, role
models-- because I
didn't know anything but
tennis-- is all tennis figures.
So John McEnroe, the ability for
him to play the kind of shots
that nobody else
did was one thing.
But something about
his personality,
this rebellious
nature, and I think
there's something that wanted
to break out of the mold for me,
and John McEnroe did it.
And I thought, wow,
very encouraging.
It's something that he's
not ashamed to be different.
That really allowed me
to have him as an idol.
MEGAN SMITH: Amazing person.
So what's some of the
best advice either of you
guys got that you can think of?
Or things that you
did that you were
like, that with the
right thing to do.
You know, when you kind of
hit a fork or you're like,
should I go this
way or that way?
What were some of the moments
that you can think of?
YOKY MATSUOKA:
Those are hard ones.
CORI LATHAN: Just a small--
maybe more of an anecdote.
I found that the verbal advice--
I'm a gatherer of information,
so I think I tend to get
advice from a lot of people
and then synthesize
and make a decision,
so it's hard to
think of one thing.
But when I was probably 11 or
12 or 13, that formative time,
I did a summer camp
with a dance teacher.
And it wasn't so much what
this dance teacher said to me.
He made me come out
of myself and not
worry about what
other people we're
saying or thinking or doing.
And so it was one
of the times, I
think a very important time
in my life, where it was,
listen to your gut.
It was, be who you are.
And he made me dance in front of
people, and I am not a dancer.
So that was actually, I think,
a great formative moment
in the form of physical advice.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Interesting.
Yeah.
I think mine is a really
weird, but let me just try.
Ignorance.
I sort of mentioned
this a little bit.
Sometimes, when you
are thinking too much,
just stop thinking about
it, and just let go,
seems to actually help.
So I think we all
like to analyze it
to death about some things.
I shouldn't do this,
and this is not--
I'm not going to be good at it,
so I really shouldn't do it.
I think that thought
process-- sometimes
it's good to just
say, you know what,
I'm just not going
to worry about it.
It's easy to say, hard to do.
As well as, I think
some of us-- and I
think you mentioned a little
bit about not noticing,
and I also feel like I
didn't notice how few of us
were around until pretty late.
And that really helped me to get
through some of those moments.
And I think that's
one of the things
that-- if there is
some ignorance that we
can put in ourselves, I
think that'd be great.
MEGAN SMITH: You know
what's interesting is
that we do unconscious bias
training on all Googlers,
and one of the
things we learn is--
there's a study that
shows if there's
10 characteristics
for a job, on average,
men will apply if they
have at least three,
and women will apply for jobs
if they have at least seven.
And so I think in some ways
maybe women are conditioned,
or they're automatically saying,
I need more qualifications,
I need more information.
Once I have all these skills,
then I can apply for that.
And some of the guys are
maybe being socialized
to just, hey, you have enough,
you have a piece of it, go.
To me, what you were
saying tied into that.
YOKY MATSUOKA: I totally agree.
So in high school, I
heard similar stats
that boys who have B minus
average in math and physics
would apply to engineering.
Girls would not apply unless
they have an A average.
And it's the same concept.
And unfortunately,
they're biased things.
So as you go on, the women
who actually lasted til then
tend to be those A player.
But somehow, for boys,
it's OK to have a range.
So if we can actually start
to change that even earlier
in the pipeline, saying,
you're getting B minus in math?
Great!
Keep going!
Engineering, apply for it.
There is definitely
a place for you.
MEGAN SMITH: Right, because
part of it is book smart,
but a lot of it is practical,
physical intuition stuff.
And you can--
apprentice, journeyman,
master-- you can
learn these things.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Exactly.
MEGAN SMITH: So what is
something that you've
seen recently, or
some of the things
you've seen that you're just
like, oh my god, I love that.
I've been waiting
for that to show up.
Or something that in your
research or work you're doing,
or something you've seen from
another company or research
team, or from a
science fair kid?
Anything out there that's been
really cool that people should
know about that
you can think of?
CORI LATHAN: I
think that for me,
the area of brain-computer
interaction and brain science
and sensors in robotics and
all of that coming together.
The World Economic Forum just
released their top 10 emerging
technologies for 2014,
and quantified self
was one of them-- brain-computer
interfaces and body wearable
sensors.
And to me, that really
encapsulated the ecosystem
that I want to be
part of going forward.
The ability for us to really
understand our brain function,
and then use that information to
interact with our environment.
And going back to our moon shot
idea, eliminating disability.
Eliminating aging.
I mean, we're all
disabled in some way
because we can't do
everything we want to do.
And so really enabling
the human being
through these technologies
over the next one, three,
five years is going
to be amazing.
MEGAN SMITH: And I
also like your point
about teams, because
it's also enabling teams.
I mean, we see
the basics of that
in Wikipedia, a
global team of sharing
what we know with each other.
CORI LATHAN: We think of
human-machine interaction
as one human and one machine.
But really, it's human to
machine to human to machine--
MEGAN SMITH: And to each other
and all mixed up, globally.
YOKY MATSUOKA: I don't know.
One of the things that I'm
really excited that we don't
necessarily have yet but we're
in the right trajectory to get
is mommy technology.
So I think a lot of
the technologies,
because they're built by men,
they serve a lot of things
that men like.
But I think we are moving a
very right direction where we're
putting technology
infused homes.
For example, not to be
[? netcentric ?] view
of thinking about it, but
that is now going to make
mommy's tasks of
tracking kids or some
of the duties a
little bit easier.
And the more technology
interface women
get to have, the
more chance the women
get to understand the technology
itself and says, oh geez,
I can contribute to this
way of thinking technology,
and realize that they can do,
and they can become engineers,
and they can jump in.
And I think that is a
good positive feedback.
MEGAN SMITH: I completely agree.
And also just in general,
parents, and helping moms
have an easier time so they can
participate more, and helping
the guys, the dads, be able to
participate in different ways
that they haven't
been welcome or in.
I think it's going to
really change things a lot.
Very insightful.
So that's a wrap.
I want to thank Yoky
and Cori for being
here-- amazing
robotics brain trust.
This is women tech
makers, and we'll
see you in the next shows.